สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
13 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายน
อืปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
2022 อืตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้ 15
น 8 นค่ะค่ะ 158 นูเรียมสบายดีนะคะใช่ค่ะ
สบายดีค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้รู้สึกแบบเบื่อๆนิด
นึงค่ะเอ้าทำไมล่ะทำไมเบื่อๆล่ะคะก็แบบ
เราเราก็แบบใช้ชีวิตของเรามานานๆแล้วมี
หลายอย่างที่เราทำแล้วมันเหมือนเดิมอืเรา
ไปอยู่บ้านหลังเดิมเราไปกินข้าวที่เดิม
เราได้เจอคนเดิมๆเดมก็เลยรู้สึกแบบอืมี
อะไรที่แปลกๆใหม่ๆบ้างมยโออยากจะเปลี่ยน
หรอคะไม่อยากเป็นตัวเองหรอคะครูเรียมอื
วันนี้รู้สึกว่าไม่อยากเป็นตัวเองอแต่
เป็นตัวเองก็ดีนะแต่แบบอยากมีประสบการณ์
บางอย่างที่แปลกๆอ๋อที่แไม่ใช่เราในทุกๆ
วันใช่เรียมก็เลยคิดว่าเดี๋ยวในวันนี้ที่
เรามาสอนภาษาไทยกันเรียมอยากให้เราพูดถึง
ว่าถ้าเราเป็นใครได้ 1 คนที่ไม่ใช่ตัวเรา
นะครูหญิงอยากจะเป็นใครเรียมอยากจะเป็น
ใครเป็นใครก็ได้หรอคะใช่คนที่ตายไปแล้ว
ได้ไหได้คนที่แบบ 100 ปีที่แล้วได้มยได้
อืครูคนที่ไม่มีจริงๆได้มยแบบเป็น
คาแรคเตอร์ในหนังแบบ Harry  Potter  Iron
Man  Superman อะไรเงี้ยได้มยคะแบบใครก็
ได้ได้ค่ะได้
ออผู้หญิงอยากจะเป็นใครผู้หญิงคิดคิดคิด
ิดๆครูหญิงคิดนะคะว่าถ้าเราจะเป็นใครสัก
คนนึงเนี่ยเป็นเป็นได้กี่วันคะครูเรียม 1
วัน 2 วัน 3 วัน 1 วัน 1 คืน 1 วัน 1 คืน
ก็คือ 24 ช่วงชั่วโมงใช่มั้ยคะใช่ออครู
หญิงก็คิดว่าถ้าเราจะเป็นใครสักคนนึง
เนี่ยเราต้องเป็นใครก็ได้ที่ไม่เหมือนเรา
เพราะถ้าเหมือนกันมันจะรู้สึกถ้าู้หญิงไป
เป็นครูเรียมเราก็เป็นคนไทยเหมือนกันเป็น
ผู้หญิงเหมือนกันอมันก็จะไม่ได้รู้สึกแบบ
แตกต่างขนาดนั้น
เนาะใช่ครูหญิง
เนี่ยคิด
ว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยอยากจะเป็นคนนี้ค่ะครู
เรียมใครคะให้ดูรูปได้มยถ้านักเรียนเห็น
รูปครูหญิงคิดว่านักเรียนรู้จักแน่นอน
อืมนี่ค่ะ
ออควีน
เอลิซาเบธใช่นะควีนเอลิซาเบธหรือว่าอะไร
ราชินีเอลิซาเบธเหรอคนไทยก็เรียกควีน
เอลิซาเบธใช่คที่ 2 นะคะคเอลิซาเบธที่ 2
คุณหญิงอยากเป็นค่ะ 24 ชมอือยากเป็นทำไม
ล่ะคะครูหญิงผู้หญิงอยากจะรู้สึกอะไรหรอ
อยากจะรู้อะไรหรอ 1 เไม่ใช่คนประเทศเรานะ
คะแล้วก็ 2 คือแบบชีวิตคงไม่เหมือนเราแน่
นอนน่ะครูหญิงก็อยากจะรู้ว่าถ้าเราต้อง
เป็นควีนของประเทศประเทศนึงในเวลา 24 ชมง
ทำอะไรบ้างกิน
อะไรเป็นยังไงเหนื่อยมั้ยเครียดมั้ยและมี
ชีวิตที่ไม่เหมือนเรายังไงอออ่าเพราะว่า
แบบคือเราเคยอาจจะเคยดูซีรียส์เคยดูหนัง
ที่มีเรื่องราวเกี่ยวกับควีนของแต่ละ
ประเทศเงี้ยควีนของอังกฤษคิงของอังกฤษ
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะแต่แค่แต่เราไม่ได้ไปเป็น
เป็นเ้าจริงๆไงมันอาจจะไม่เหมือนกันก็ได้
คุณหญิงก็เลยอยากรู้ว่าคนที่เา้าเป็นควีน
เป็นคิงอย่างเงี้ยใน 1 วันน่ะเคทำอะไร
บ้างเค้าเป็นยังไงก็เลยอยากเป็นเพราะมัน
รู้สึกว่าแตกต่างกับเรามากๆเลยอ่ะค่ะก็
เลยรู้สึกออยากเป็นนะแล้วู้หญิงอยากรู้
ได้มยว่าแบบเป็นคนนั้นเรู้สึกยังไงอืใช่
มยได้ไงก็แบบรู้สึก 1 วันต้องคิดอะไรบ้าง
อ่ะหรือว่าเราต้องเพราะว่าคุณหญิงอย่าง
คุณหญิงเคยดูเหมือนเคยดูซีรียส์ที่เกี่ยว
กับควีนเอลิซาเบธอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วรู้สึก
ว่าเออแค่ดูซีรียส์เราก็รู้สึกว่าแบบถ้า
เราเลือกได้เราก็ไม่อยากเป็นน่ะคือเรารู้
สึกไงแต่พอเรารู้สึกว่าเออแล้วถ้าเราต้อง
โดนให้เป็นควีนของประเทศอย่างเงี้ยเราจะ
รู้สึกอะไรหรอแล้วไ 1 วันเนี่ยต้องทำงาน
อะไรบ้างเจอใครบ้างเงี้ยก็เลยรู้สึกเออ
อยากลองดูนะคะจะได้แบบเข้าใจคนที่มีชีวิต
ไม่เหมือนเราเลยคนที่ต้องอยู่ใน
โลกในสื่อตลอดเวลาแบบออกไปข้างนอกก็มีคน
รู้จักเราอ่ะอย่างคุณหญิงเดินไปที่ไหนก็
ไม่มีใครรู้ใช่ไหมมคะว่าคือใครสบายมากๆ
เลยเออก็เลยแบบอยากลองเป็นอะไรที่แตกต่าง
กับเราดูอืมแต่ว่าเรียมบอกว่าเป็นได้แค่ 1
วัน 1 คืนเอืครูหญิงคงไม่ได้อยากเป็นไป
ตลอดใช่มั้ยอืไม่ค่ะไม่ครูหญิงชอบเป็นตัว
เองนี่แหละสบายดีแล้วค่ะอืใช่ๆเหมือน
เรียมก็เหมือนกันสบายดีจนแบบรู้สึกเออก็
ก็ทุกอย่างก็โอเคแต่ว่าวันนี้ก็อยาก
เปลี่ยนไปบ้างอยากเปลี่ยนไปเป็นอะไรที่
แตกต่างเรียมแล้วครูเรียมล่ะเพราะว่าครู
หญิงเป็นแล้วใช่มั้ยคะแล้วครูเรียมอ่ะนัก
เรียนก็ต้องอยากรู้ว่าถ้าครูเรียมเนี่ย
เป็นใครก็ได้ 1 คนใน 1 วันใน 24 ชมงเนี่ย
1 วัน 1 คืนเนี่ยครูเรียมอยากเป็นใคร
คะ 1 คือเรียมอยากเปลี่ยนเป็นผู้ชายอ๋อ
คือไม่เอาที่แบบเป็นผู้หญิงเหมือนเราเนาะ
เพราะเข้าใจแล้วผู้หญิงเป็นยังไงใช่ๆอยาก
เปลี่ยนเป็นผู้ชายอยากรู้ว่าผู้ชายคิดยัง
ไงแล้วผู้ชายที่เรียมอยากเปลี่ยนไปเป็น
เนี่ยก็คือนักเขียนคนนึงอืมเพราะว่าครู
เรียมชอบอ่านหนังสือใช่มั้ยใช่ๆๆแล้ว
เนี่ยเรียมก็เลยหารูปเ้ามาแต่ว่าเคเสีย
ชีวิตไปแล้วนะคะค่ะเคเป็นนักเขียนประเทศ
อะไรคะครูเรียมอยู่เลบานอนนะคะ
อชื่อชื่ออะไรคะชื่อคารินคารินยิบรานค่ะ
คารินยิบราน
อืทำไมครูเรียมอยากเป็นเค้าอ่ะเพราะว่า
จริงๆก็มีนักเขียนในโลกนี้เยอะแยะมากมาย
ทำไมครูเรียมถึงอยากเป็นนักเขียนคนนี้คะ
เรียมรู้สึกว่าเค้าเขียนหนังสือได้แบบมัน
ลึกอ่ะความรู้สึกมันลึกมากถึงแบบไม่ใช่
สิ่งทั่วๆไปที่เราจะคิดได้อืิมก็เลยอยาก
รู้ว่าเค้าใช้ชีวิตมายังไงเคต้องเจออะไร
บ้างอืมนั่นแหละแล้วแบบอเค้ามีประสบการณ์
อะไรบ้างเดมก็เลยแบบอยากลองเป็นเค้าสัก 1
วันค่ะเอก็ก็คิดว่าอ่าจจะเขียนหนังสือ
เก่งขึ้นถ้าได้เป็น
เค้าไม่ได้สิคะพอเราเป็นเค้าเสร็จแล้ววัน
ต่อมาเราก็ต้องกลับมาเป็นตัวเองเหมือน
เดิมเราก็จะมีความคิดเป็นของตัวเราเหมือน
เดิมความเก่งที่เป็นของตัวเราเหมือนเดิม
เราไม่ได้ได้ของเขามาด้วยเออแต่ก็อยากไป
รู้แหละว่าวันนึงคืนนึงเทำอะไรบ้างแล้ว
มันเป็นแบบคนที่อยู่ในสมัยก่อนดยไงคะ
เรียมก็คิดว่าสิ่งแวดล้อมบ้านแล้วก็
ประเทศที่เขาอยู่คนที่อยู่รอบๆเขาอ่ะมัน
จะแตกต่างจากเราอืก็เลยคิดว่าคงจะเป็น
อะไรที่น่าตื่นเต้นมาก
เค้าอยู่ในช่วงปีอะไรอ่ะครูเรียมรู้มั้ย
คะแบบเค้ามีชีวิตอยู่ในช่วงปีปีพ.ศหรือ
ว่าปีค.ศอะไรปีค.ศหรอหนังสือที่เขาขายมา
เนี่ย
นะอหูอันนี้แบบมันมันเผยแพร่ตั้งแต่ปี
1892 แล้วอ่ะคือมันนานมากแปว่าเค้ามี
ชีวิตมากกว่าแบบ 200  100 ปีที่แล้วใช่มย
คะใช่นคิดว่าอ๋อนี่ไงนี่ไงเเกิดเเกิดปี
1883 ออ
1883 ก็อ๋อประมาณ 100 ปีที่แล้วเท่านั้น
นะคะประมาณ 100 คือก็ถ้าเขายังมีชีวิต
อยู่ก็ 139 เนาะใช่ใช่ม 1883 ใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่ๆ 1883 นั่นแหละเตรมก็แบบในปี 1  8
1883 ที่ประเทศ
เลบานอนมีผู้ชายคนนึงเกิดขึ้น
มาแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นเอออยากรู้เอแล้วครู
เรียมอยากเป็นอยากเป็นเค้าในเพราะว่าเค้า
ไม่อยู่แล้วใช่มั้ยคะแล้วครูเรียมอยาก
เป็นเค้าตอนอายุเท่าไหร่ิมอยากเป็นเค้า
ตอน
ตอนที่อายุ
ประมาณ 10 กว่า 17  18
อืเพราะว่าถ้าครูหญิงครูหญิงอยากเป็นควีน
เอลิซาเบธตอนที่น่าจะอายุ 25  26 หรือ
เปล่าอ่ะเอเปลี่ยนใจอีกแล้วเนาะเป็นตอน
ที่วันที่เขาขึ้นเป็นควีนในเพะว่าควีน
เอลิซาเบธก็เสียชีวิตไปแล้วเหมือนกันเนาะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเราก็เลยเลือกอายุกันดีกว่าอื
ๆๆเออๆๆอ่ะแล้วทำไมครูเรียมอยากเป็นเค้า
ตอนอายุ 1718 ลอคะหรอเรมก็ไม่ได้รู้
เรื่องชีวิตเเยอะนะแต่รู้ว่าแบบเค้าเคย
แบบผิดหวังเรื่องความรักแล้วก็มีแต่ง
หนังสือขึ้นมาอืแต่ว่าเค้าเคค่อนข้างที่
จะใช้ชีวิตเร็วนะคะแบบแบบไม่ใช่ใช้ชีวิต
เร็วสิแบบเหมือนมีประสบการณ์จากชีวิตที่
เขาใช้อ่ะเก็บประสบการณ์มาเยอะแล้วก็
เรื่อยๆอชีวิตก็เปลี่ยนแปลงไปเรื่อยๆแต่
ว่าเป็นนักเขียนนะส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยผลงานก็จะ
ไม่ได้มีชื่อเสียงตอนที่นักเขียนมีอายุ
ยังมีชีวิตอยู่เหมือนนักวาดรูปเลยใช่
เหมือนนักวาดรูปเวลาที่เขาตายไปแล้วอ่ะผล
งานเขถึงแบบเออเป็นที่รู้จักมากขึ้นอือาจ
จะเป็นนักเขียนที่เหมือนกับไม่ใช่นัก
เขียนที่เขียนนิยายหรือว่าเขียนอะไรที่
แบบมันค่อนข้างจะแสหน่อยมยอาจะเป็นนัก
เขียอาจจะเป็นที่ยุคสมัยด้วยแหละเมาอือๆ
สมัยนี้ก็คือแบบเข้าร้านหนังสือก็แบบขาย
หนังสือได้อะไรประมาณเนี้ยทำหนังสือมาเรา
อยากให้คนเห็นเราก็มีวิธีทำให้คนเห็นใน
สมัยนี้แต่สมัยนั้นมันไม่ใช่ออือคุณเรียม
ก็เลยอยากจะเป็นใช่มเออเนาะมันก็เป็นแบบ
เพราะว่าการที่เราจะเป็นใคร 1 คนมันต้อง
เหมือนเราต้องไปรู้ชีวิตเค้าอ่ะคือถึงแม้
เราจะเป็นได้แค่ 1 วันน่ะแต่เราก็ไปรู้
ชีวิตเค้าใน 1 วันเนาะว่าเค้าแบบตื่นนอน
กี่โมงตื่นนอนเสร็จแล้วทำอะไรกินอะไรกิน
ข้าวเสร็จต้องทำงานแล้วชีวิตเค้าในแต่ละ
วันเข้าเค้าวางแผนเ้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะคะ
กิจวัตรประจำวันน่ะเนาะว่าในแต่ละวันเค้า
ทำอะไรบ้างอใช่แล้วเวลาที่เขาเห็นสิ่งนึง
เนี่ยเคคิดอะไรเออเออนั่นแหละที่อยากเป็น
เพมันไม่ได้เหมือนกันไงใช่มยเพราะว่า
อย่างของูหญิงอยากเป็นควีนเอลิซาเบธเพราะ
ว่าอยากรู้ว่าเออการที่เราต้องเป็นควีน
ของ
ประเทศมันเป็นยังไงนนาความรู้สึกอใช่ของ
เรามันเป็นยังไงเออใช่เรียว่ามันมัน
เกี่ยวกับความรู้สึกมากๆอืมันประสบการณ์
เป็นอีกส่วนหนึ่งแต่ความรู้สึกก็คือเป็น
สิ่งที่เมอยากอยากรู้อยากสัมผัสอืเพราะ
ว่าแบบเราก็คือเราใช่มั้ยเราก็รู้สึกเรา
เป็นตัวเราอ่ะสมมุติเราเป็นครูเราก็รู้
สึกอ่ะเราต้องทำยังไงต้องเจอนักเรียนแค่
นั้นนะแต่ว่าแบบคนที่เา้าทำงานไม่เหมือน
กับเราอาชีพไม่เหมือนกับเราใช่เคคิดอะไร
เนาะในแต่ละวันผู้หญิงอย่างเงี้ยค่ะเป็น
คนที่ไม่ได้เขียนหนังสือเก่งเลยจริงๆการ
ที่แบบคนๆนึงจะเขียนหนังสือขึ้นมาหรือว่า
เป็นนักเขียนที่เก่งๆเออพอต้องคิดอะไร
เนาะถึงจะเขียนให้เก่งๆอือใช่ๆนั่นแหละ
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนถ้าเป็นใครคน
นึงได้ 1 วัน 1 คืนนักเรียนอยากจะเป็นใคร
อืแล้วทำไมอยากเป็นคนๆ
นั้นใช่เราก็จะได้ลองกลับไปลองคิด
ดู
อืใช่ค่ะใช่แต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วใช่
มั้ยคะครูหญิงเวลาหมดแล้วเหรอคะครูเรียมู
หญิงว่ามันเริ่ม 8 นาทีมั้ยอ้าเหรอจริง
หรอไหนครูเรียมเช็คสิคะออเรียมนึกว่าเลข
3 คุณหญิงรู้มั้ยเรียมก็แบบหาทางลงอยู่
เรียมนึกว่าแบบเวลาหมด
แล้วเอ๊เราเริ่ม 8 หน้าเห็นมยครูดีนะคะ
ที่ครูเรียมย้อนกลับไปดูได้เพราะว่าบาง
ครั้งครูจำเวลาไม่ค่อยได้ไงเอใช่ๆถ้า
อย่างงั้นเลือกอีกสักคนดีกว่าดิมก็อยาก
ให้เลือกอีกสักคนก็เลือกอีกสักคนนึงหรอ
ครูหญิงอยากจะเป็นคิมคาเดชทำไมครูหญิง
เลือกอยากเป็นแต่ผู้หญิงอ่ะไม่เอาดีกว่า
เป็นผู้ชายดีกว่าคืออย่างเป็นคิมเดชนเแบบ
ว่าชีวิตคุณต้องอยู่ใน Reality ตลอดเวลา
มันรู้สึกอะไรหรอกรู้สึกยังไงใช่่ม
อ้อผู้หญิงต้องมีความ
แบบใช่ไม่เอาดีกว่าแต่คูหญิงเป็นผู้หญิง
ไปแล้วไงคือแบบคือถ้าให้ครูหญิงพูดถึงว่า
คือด้วยความที่ควีนเอลิซาเบธเนี่ยนะคะก็
เพิ่งสวรรคตเนาะคนไทยเป็นควีนเนาะก็จะ
เป็นคำราชาศัพท์ใช่มั้ยหรือว่าเสียชีวิต
ใช่มั้ยคะถ้ามันถ้าอย่างงั้นน่ะครูหญิงก็
เลือกได้นะเหมือนที่ครูหญิงบอกครูเรียม
ว่าคุหญิงก็อยากเป็นเาในช่วงวันที่ขึ้น
เป็นควีนอืวันที่ 20 ตอนที่เขาอายุน่าจะ
เช็คจากอินเทอร์เน็ตนะคะน่าจะอายุประมาณ
26 ปีอือืเพราะว่าแบบก็อยากจะรู้ว่า
เออณตอนนั้นรู้สึกอะไรหรอดีใจ
มหรือว่าเสียใจตื่นเต้นกลัวรือแบบตกใจ
เพราะว่าโดยส่วนใหญ่นะคะคนที่จะขึ้นเป็น
คิงหรือว่าขึ้นเป็นควีนก็วันที่เราเป็นก็
คือวันที่คุณพ่อของเราเสียชีวิตอืออืพอ
คุณพ่อเราเสียปุ๊บเราก็ต้องขึ้นเป็นคนต่อ
ไปอย่างเงี้ยมันจะมีความรู้สึกอะไรหรอเออ
ออก็แบบไม่รู้สิก็ไม่รู้ว่าจะต้องรู้สึก
แต่ถ้าเป็นใช่แต่ถ้าเป็นอีกหนคนครูหญิงขอ
เป็นผู้ชายได้มคะครูเรียมยคิดอยู่ว่าจะ
เป็นเดวิดเฮมดีมนอ้าแล้วถ้าครูหญิงเป็น
เดวิดแบคแฮมครูหญิงคิดว่ามันจะเป็นยังไง
ครูหญิงจะได้เป็นรู้นคือถ้าครูหญิงเป็น
เดวิดเบคแฮมครูหญิงขอเป็นช่วงเวลาที่เขา
ยังเป็นนักฟุตบอลนะคะเลือกได้มเขาก็จะออก
กำลังกายหนักมากนะคะผูหญิงเออใชู่หญิง
อยากแบบเป็นวันที่เขาต้องเป็นนักฟุตบอล
แล้วก็ต้องต้องไปเตะฟุตบอลในแบบในวันที่
อาจจะต้องเตะแล้วเถ้าทีมเ้าชนะเต้องได้
เป็นแชมป์อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอ่าอาจจะไปเป็น
แบบพวก World  Cup หรือว่า
ยูโรคัพหรือว่าอาจจะเป็นวันที่เขายังเป็น
นักเตะในทีม Manchester  United อย่า
เงี้ยแล้ววันที่เขาต้องแข่ง
กับทีม 1 ทีมแล้วเต้องถ้าต้องทำให้
แมนเชสเตอร์ชนะเพื่อที่เขาจะได้เป็นแชมป์
อย่างเงี้ยคืออยากจะรู้ว่าเ
ต้องทำอะไรบ้างในการเป็นนักฟุตบอลที่มี
ชื่อเสียงมากๆจนถึงปัจจุบันนี้อ่าอืใช่
แล้วแบบแล้วเขาก็ค่อนข้างมีชื่อเสียงใช่ม
เพราะฉะนั้นก็เลยเออแล้วมันจะเป็นยังไง
เนาะความรู้สึกที่เราต้องเป็นคนดังไปทำไม
เลือกเป็นคนแต่เป็นคนอังกฤษเนาะไม่ได้
ตั้งใจนะเป็นคนอังกฤษใช่มยคนอังกฤษหมดเลย
ผู้หญิงเรียมนึกออกแล้วว่าเรียมอยากไป
เป็นใครอีกคนนึงเรียมครูเรียมอยากเป็นใคร
อีก 1 คนคะเรียมอยากเป็นนักบิน
อวกาศ
พอเอ้ยเชื่อพอน Armstrong เหรอน Armstrong
ใช่ริมอยากรู้ว่าวันที่เ้าไปเหยียบดวง
จันทร์แล้วแบบมันต้องเจออะไรบ้างตอนที่
ขึ้นไปเนาะใช่ตอนที่ขึ้นไปบนยานอวกาศแล้ว
ก็ขึ้นไปข้างบนรู้สึกยังไงอตอนที่ไป
เหยียบบนดวงจันทร์รู้สึกยังไงอืแล้วเวลา
ที่เห็น
โลกผ่านการยืนจากดวงจันทร์น่ะเห็นโลกแล้ว
มันแบบว้าวมแบบว้าวโลกแบบนี้มั้เราเห็น
โลกเป็นวงกลมไม่ได้เห็นจากอินเทอร์เน็ต
ไม่ได้เห็นจากรูปภาพเราอยู่อีกที่นึงแล้ว
ก็มองโลกจริงๆครูหญิงอ่ะตอนครูเรียมถาม
ตอนแรกนะครูหญิงก็อยากเป็นคาแรคเตอร์ 1
คาแรคเตอร์ที่ขับยานอวกาศอ่ะเหมือนแบบอ
สมมติ Star  Wars อย่างเงี้ยก็อาจจะเป็น
ฮานโซโลใช่มั้ยที่ขับมินเนียม Falcon
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอยากรู้ว่าแบบเออแล้วจะไป
ตอบ David  Back แมทำไมใช่มั้ยคะแต่พอครู
เรียมพูดแล้วก็เลยนึกขึ้นหนไงว่าเออใช่ณ
ตอนแรกอ่ะแต่เราแค่คิดไม่ออกว่าเราจะเป็น
คาแรคเตอร์ไหนดีอ่ะเพราะว่าพอครูเรียมพูด
ก็เลยนึกขึ้นได้ว่าเออเราก็อยากเห็นเรา
ไม่ได้อยากขับรถอยู่บนถนนน่ะอืแล้วเราก็
ไม่อยากขับเครื่องบินเพราะเครื่องบนมันก็
เห็นแค่ก้อนเมฆไงเออธรรมดามากอใช่ๆๆเออ
แล้วครูเรียมอยากจะเป็นน Armstrong ในวัน
ที่เขึ้นไปเหยียบดวงจันทร์ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ๆ
นั่นแหละเรียมว่ามันมันหาความรู้สึกแบบ
นั้นไม่ได้ที่นี่มันอือแค่นั้นเองไม่ใช่
แค่ที่นี่มันต้องคนหลายๆคนก็ไม่ได้มีใคร
ที่จะมีโอกาสขึ้นไปเหยียบดวงจันทร์นะคะ
ครูเรียมแล้วก่อนที่ครูเรียมจะขึ้นไปถึง
ดวงจันทร์ครูเรียมก็ต้องอยู่ในจรวดหรอยาน
อวกาศจรวดสรุไม่รูู้หญิไม่รู้ว่านิว
Armstrong อยู่อยู่ในอะไรขึ้นไปบนดวง
จันทร์น่ะเออแล้วแบบต้องกินอะไรหรอแล้ว
เวลามันเป็นยังไงอ่ะอืเออไม่แน่นะอาจจะ
แบบพอได้เป็น 1 วัน 1 คืนแล้วกลับมาก็รู้
สึกว่าเฮ้ยอยากเป็นแบบนั้นอีกหรือแบบไม่
เอาอีกแล้วเป็นแบบนี้ดีแล้วแต่เราเดีที่
สุดแล้วไม่
เหนื่อยเใช่นั่นแหละค่ะก็ก็เหมือนเดิมนะ
คะนักเรียนอยากเป็นใครก็คอมเมนต์บอกเรา
ได้นะคะว่าอยากเป็นใครทำไมอยากเป็นหรือ
ว่าแค่นั้นแหละใช่แค่นั้นแหละอะไต่อแค่น
ไม่
ใช่โอเคหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะต้องลาไปก่อนแล้ว
ค่ะครูหญิงไปจริงๆแล้วนะคะโอเคสวัสดีค่ะ
คุณสัสดีค่ะบ๊าย
บาย